foreign
's YouTube channel in this session we
will learn how to eliminate a selected
column in an existing table in SQL but
before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have daily updates on multiple
Technologies if you're a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for latest technological
Trends then consider getting subscribed
to our YouTube channel and don't forget
to hit that Bell icon to never miss an
update from Simply learn now without
further Ado let's get started with our
one point agenda that is how to
eliminate a selected column in a SQL
table
now let's quickly take a look at the
syntax that we will be following to
execute this particular command
the syntax is as follows we will be
using the alter table keyword then the
table name way we want to eliminate the
column followed by that the drop column
keyword and the column name now let's
get back to these equal workmans to
execute this particular command now here
on the SQL workbench and you can see we
have five different columns over here
and we have the phone number column
which does not have anything now we will
try to eliminate this particular phone
number column since we do not need that
for our purposes now the command is
really simple as discussed before we
will be using the alter table keyword
and the table name and the drop column
keyword and the phone number which is
the column name now let's quickly
execute this particular command and see
the output there you go now the column
phone number has been successfully
eliminated now let's run the select
command once again and see the new table
there you go the phone number column has
been successfully eliminated now with
that we have come to an end of this
session on how to eliminate a selected
column in an existing table in SQL if
you have any queries regarding any of
the topics covered in the session or if
you require the resources like the PPT
code and the data set that we used in
this session then do let us know in the
comment section below and our team of
experts will be more than happy to
resolve all your queries at the earliest
until next time thank you stay safe and
keep learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here